[Music]
5 44 on your wednesday morning what's
driving to crazy we will talk about the
complete closure of i-15 but for now
we're talking about
getting to the va hospital in the far
northeast valley that may drive you
crazy
at least for the next month now
depending on what part of town you're
coming from it's already kind of a track
to get to the va hospital without a day
the city of north las vegas is starting
an approximately 30 day
storm drainage construction project that
is completely closing
pecos from centennial parkway north to
the entrance to the hospital
during the work the only way to get to
the hospital will be from the north
so drivers who would normally use pecos
northbound from centennial parkway
well you can go west to losi or east
over delam
then north on the 215 and then over to
pecos if you have business at the
hospital or if you work there
you're going to have to give yourself
extra time because this is going to be a
big delay now all this information is on
our website eight newsnow dot com you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me with pictures and video to
traffic eight
eight newsnow.com